now you as the performer
are you seeing this happen to you that
you're just not viewing people as people
you're becoming dehumanized or no I
would say yes but it first happens with
you you detach yourself from reality
because number one you're going by
pseudonym you don't even go by your real
name so it's interesting that the first
thing that the director promised me is I
can make your name famous but the first
thing that happened was my name actually
died because if I can detach you from
any kind of belief in you know there's
some kind of moral you know aspect of
this that I should or shouldn't be doing
if I'm calling myself by another name
then it detaches you from it because and
it covers the shame you Joshua Broome
have a mother you have a God you have an
upbringing you have a moral sense yeah
at least some kind of moral sense that
you but you whatever your performer name
is right well that guy just he just got
invented five minutes ago